i think they're the trump supporters
should start a maga party
or something like that and uh
i think they need to stand on principle
and do it no matter what i'm sick and
tired of the
i'm gonna vote for a republican just
because it's better than democrats
because then you end up with mitch
mcconnell
who at a moment's notice is like turn
around i got a knife i gotta point here
real quick
so what what's the point of supporting
any of these guys can we start the white
party
then we can have the red the white and
the blue party that sounds like a
terrible idea
is it gonna be too racist
[Laughter]
that doesn't sound the way you think it
sounds ian i'm not racial
[Laughter]
the maga party will be orange there you
go it will be orange yeah that's a good
idea
the orange yep uh i like it i'll start
the white part
yeah that'd be cool if we had red white
and blue states yeah those are the
colors of russia
in ohio and france who are you working
for the french
oh the french french white state alone
no uh no but i think they i don't know
you're right it's too racist
i don't i don't care if if look uh we've
already heard a bunch of republicans
saying sacrifice to senate
i shouldn't say i'm sorry trump
supporters are saying sacrifice the
senate
lin wood and tiny power basically like
don't vote for republicans
and it's funny because i'm like yeah i
don't care either like we go through
this
like every election and the same thing
with bernie bros
you know they they'll come and they'll
be like well you gotta you gotta vote
for our party because you don't wanna
vote for the fascists or you don't wanna
vote for the socialists so you gotta
vote for us and then they have no
incentive to do it to do what we want we
had donald trump as the president
and the republican still would not enact
the policies that he
he he campaigned on so why why should we
vote for him why should the left vote
for the democrats why should the right
vote for the republicans
make them do work have you have you have
you been following what's going on with
jimmy dore
no so jimmy dore is awesome and jimmy
dore said
that aoc and the other progressive
democrats can force a floor
vote on medicare for all and she's
basically said no it can't be done
we don't have the votes and blah blah
and so jimmy's point and he's getting
attacked for it by a bunch of
progressives because he dare
question aoc he said if 14 or 15
progressives said we will not vote for
nancy pelosi as speaker of the house
unless we get a floor vote on medicare
for all she will
do it because she will lose the
speakership and probably to a republican
so of course she would and then the
response they give to jimmy is
but it won't work and then we won't get
medicare from be a waste of time and
it's like what's the
so what so what's the worst case
scenario it gets voted down then jimmy
said then we'll know exactly who voted
against this but he brings up a really
good point
after everything aoc has campaigned on
she won't
have she does not have the political
will because she's a careerist
who's thinking about herself that's why
she fired the people you know she got
rid of of the people that were around
her
that helped her get where she was it's
why she pushed them away and it's why
she walked back from some of her more
extreme positions as soon as she got
elected
because she's thinking about the next
two years and her career that's what
she's interested in
you know what i understand that she's
she was she was a bartender
right and i mean i i there's no
disrespect i think it's fantastic that
she was a bartender and got elected
and now she's probably sitting there
thinking without this i'm just i'm
nothing
and republicans remind her of that every
single day she likes to complain and say
republicans want to hold that against me
well i represent the working class and
it says right
and if you lose if you
fight the democrats and they ostracize
you and you become ineffective
and then you don't get reelected that's
where you're going back to now probably
she'll be an organizer
she'll have a tv show she would have for
sure right something like that
she's a rock star now but whether you
like it or not
but she wants this career so it's really
fascinating that she was supposed to be
this you know bastion of progressivism
and leftist values democrats
she was a card-carrying member of the
democratic socialist she gets elected
now
they're they're actually yelling at
jimmy dore because he's like do your job
do what you were vote you are elected
for and you know what i completely agree
with him
i i'm uh i like the idea of medicare for
all i don't think it can be done
i don't think that it'll win and i think
you can't just snap your fingers and
make something like that happen
but i'd like to see all the democrats
actually stand up and put their money
where their mouth is
i want to know which one of these are
just paying lip service to the
progressives pretending to care about
this
but you know what it's already been done
for me and i tell this to jimmy because
i think jimmy you're great
you want to know who would vote no on
medicare for all
it's all of them including aoc who won't
demand a floor vote there you go it's
all of them it's her included
so when he comes out and he says she
should do this it just goes to show you
i don't think it matters who you vote
for for the most part except for trump
trump was like
ready to you know like figuratively fire
off nukes to get what he wanted
build the wall find the money he was
gonna do it he fires the pentagon top
brass wants to get the troops out of
afghanistan because he's willing to make
it happen to keep his promises
every almost every single other
politician except for a couple
they're going to do the same exact thing
they're going to say i'll do this for
you vote for me and they're going to get
in and
they're gonna do nothing that's why we
need two new parties i'd love to see the
progressive start a new party
not that i think they're getting
anything done but trump supporters
certainly have political willpower
so even if they lose just so that both
parties will be split
so it's fair yes i don't care if the
republicans lose and do you
yeah i i don't but i also don't want to
permanently give
power to socialism it would be ideal
if we could have four parties populist
left populist right
establishment left establishment right
and square off and really see what
people want
if we i think if we actually had a
populist left in a populist right party
the democrats and republicans would
cease to exist in a couple cycles and
that's why i want it so bad
that's why republicans should just do it
and i'm sorry i'm sorry i keep saying
that keep saying it
trump supporters should just do it
because when i see donald trump say
that he won and i see all of the high
profile trump supporters
and even members of congress i'm like
y'all are in the trump party
own it start a new party and you can
caucus with republicans or whatever
but like already these populist
right-wing individuals are beating
republicans
they just need to do it you know what
maybe you'll lose some elections but
i'll tell you this
is it worth empowering people like mitch
mcconnell
who's going to be like give me the the
moment's notice to kick trump in the
butt
no just get don't do it if you're going
to lose if the democrats are going to
win
then make the republicans recognize they
either support you
or you walk good maybe maybe the the
democrats are i think the democrats
going to win in georgia they do
i do too trump's not on the ticket and
the republicans are dwindling the only
reason the republicans gained voters is
because of trump
and they won't support him some of them
will but mitch mcconnell won't
so i think without trump on the ticket
especially with mitch mcconnell doing
this right now
it's going to be hilarious january fits
around the corner and mitch mcconnell
just said
basically f trump don't support him at
all even in a symbolic gesture
even today trump retweeted lynn wood
saying that uh kemp is gonna be arrested
that's right
that's not gonna drive voters out in
georgia no you know what
you know what i think with mitch
mcconnell pleading he's not just saying
you know it probably would make sense if
we didn't do this he's saying
please please don't even give us
symbolic support for you know
any kind of symbol of support for trump
how many people are going to be like
okay mitch
you're right i won't i also won't give
you control of the senate you will not
be the majority leader you'll be the
minority leader and you will have no
power congratulations you've earned it
if we if if people don't stand up now
then we're just going to have the same
garbage machine churning along endlessly
and you end up with people like aoc
who's just a careerist
there's there's probably a couple real
progressives who got in but i think most
of them are just careerists
yeah of course i mean that's the whole
business of politics sell out to special
interests save your butt and get as much
as you can for yourself that's
essentially
what the system is run on but i think
another factor to really consider here
is the fact that most americans have a
lot more in common than they do
than they disagree with and when we look
at most of americans they are
disenfranchised they are sick of the
corruption they are sick of the special
interest they are sick of politicians
lying to them and taking advantage of
them which they always fricking do
so i think there's even a probable
chance of
as we're seeing this kind of political
realignment we we saw just a few years
ago according to many charts and data
a lot of people being in the moderate
kind of realm of politics we're seeing
them kind of move away from each other
more people are going towards more far
left ideas
more people are going towards more for
far-right ideas but essentially when you
look at the political spectrum it's kind
of coming together in a circle
and they might actually meet each other
and make a cohesive
force of anti-establishmentness saying
enough is enough
and if we could put aside our
differences and learn to respect each
other in a kind of republic system
where let b as other peoples want to be
left alone i think there's a possibility
that this could
essentially happen this could be
something significant you brought this
up
michael mouse brought this up divorce
yes what do you think about the idea of
like peaceful separation
i am so pro-divorced
i i want i want to split it i
absolutely i'm 100 down for it and i'm
so glad that i live in west virginia
which would be
red as hell i am i'm it's it's a second
second reddest i think uh wyoming so
uh what's funny is i hear a lot from the
left when they're like if that were to
happen
the the red states would become a third
world nation
and no no i mean maybe but you know what
i don't think the people advocating for
this
care at all i think they're like okay
have they been to new york city lately
yeah have they been to brooklyn like
have they seen the rats
land we won't have to pay for the
welfare for everybody in the cities
i the only thing that i've complained
about when the left put out their map
um we can't let them control the whole
west coast because we're gonna need
ports on the pacific
other than that i'm down for like their
proposed split i think it was like amy
scanned or something put out a proposed
map yeah i saw this land on the bottom
and then like uh united states of canada
yeah
um i was like i am so down for that
except
we need a port on the bottom we could
work out a deal with mexico
or we could just take over some of them
yeah don't you think that would happen
again maybe well another thing people
need to realize
we are on a course for a very turbulent
future
and i think succession and moving apart
just like alan west
suggested i think it's going to be a
resolution that would be the least
harmful to the rest of america if we
could just peacefully agree to
you know have our own differences to
have our own states to
live how people want to live and still
have a central national defense
but to be able to respect each other's
differences and enable more of states
rights and less of a big
centralized government i think that that
could be something that is something
that we should strive for especially now
because when we look at the future
it's going to be a very bumpy ride for
everyone i think we've reached a point
where we're
not even on the same page especially
morally
words don't even mean the same thing
yeah like having a conversation makes no
sense now
yeah we can't i don't understand how we
can be a cohesive nation
when people are speaking completely two
different languages like i
i mean i i don't it's not that extreme i
mean it's not completely different we're
both speaking english right
no we're not i mean people can learn
yeah but there's
like dictionary definitions changed to
make no sense racism in the dictionary
it was i think a web series or miriam
yeah miranda sir became circular
like it became essentially meaningless i
did i did a
a bit where i read the definition and
it's a recursive
loop because they use the word racism in
the definition of racism so it's like
because it was like it was it was like
power exerted over someone on the basis
of you know of being racist or whatever
and it's like okay
so it just never ends no there's a
there's a bunch of things that
when when i'm trying to have a
conversation with someone i have to ask
them to define certain things like
systemic racism what does that mean
you're gonna get a million different
definitions
because there's different tribes that
say things they mean different things
racism and sexism clearly do not mean
the same things to the right and to the
left
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you